how about you chuckster I want to you
know I drink about 10 to 15 20 Diet
Cokes a day I want to give up Diet Coke
oh just how about just drink water you
don't have to give up something do you
want to do you want just want to scale
it back or you going to go cold turkey I
think it's probably best for me to go
cold turkey ain't never going to Happ a
never going to happen you know I love
but we're pulling for you too thank you
brother all right no way cuz you're
drinking a diet coke right now I know I
said I got need some
help this this is Diet Coke inside of
the thing as he said the New Year
resolution is D how could this be
January so let me pour it out there it
is here here pour it in this cup right
here pour it in this cup right here
let's see it jet let's see it the last
Diet Coke of Charles Barkley's
year do it over he's look he's shaking
he's shaking right now he's shaking oh
my God it's gone uh that that is my
serious resolution give up Diet Coke
drink some water good luck with you um
do you make them yes but my my New
Year's resolution is not for me my New
Year's resolution is for anyone last
year who feel that they didn't have a
good year I'm praying and hoping that
they have a better year cuz that's very
nice I'm very suced yeah I get it but
that's you can't control that so what
can you control yes I can cuz I could
just give them that confidence to like
you know some people when they're down
they just stay down so I'm just saying
hey if you had a bad year last year
forget all that 2024 this is your year
and things will turn around and mine is
again to not procrastinate so much you
you proc you know procrastin I do there
are things
that that has nothing that has nothing
to do with procrastin I love doing that
but it's like I put stuff off I do I put
stuff I would say this if anyone
described you procrastination is never
in the Never I would never know about
and I and I need to stop that so so
that's what I'm going to work on you
want di Coke you know this stuff it
don't even taste like anything it's
water it's water he said this stuff the
coke that's what I mean he hasn't drank
a bottle of water clear stuff in this
bot it don't taste like anything but
it's good for your body your kidneys bro
you got to get your kidneys a bath
brother what are you going to do do you
really want to do this take them all out
take all those D no no
no where they at right there look man
get them all out where the D Co at where
he's high he's stashing the coke oh my
gosh look at this
[Music]
man let me get one of those to get one
too man get one oh man D Coke for
everybody yeah oh man
slice hey hey uh Shaq got any Diet Coke
over there here you go Ary thanks oh man
appreciate that got some ice put some
ice on that thing my last one put some
ice y y don't y'all feel my
pain this is good thank you boy
appreciate you ain't it good oh my God
you're going to quit this I told you how
can you do that I might give up water do
that I might give up water congrats
congratulations congrats happy new
year thanks
friends